[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
survivors of the oxford high school
shooting file a federal suit against
their school district plus jurors must
restart deliberations in the civil trial
of once beloved comedian bill cosby and
the waukesha parade massacre how a
wisconsin judge works to secure an
unbiased jury but first
i'm
terrified which is what i guess a
defamation
lawsuit is meant to do it's meant to
to take your voice weeks after a verdict
in johnny dep's favor the actor's
ex-wife speaks out in an exclusive
interview law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer for the
first time since the monumental johnny
depp versus amber heard verdict heard
speaks out in a series of exclusive
interviews for nbc
nearly three weeks ago a virginia jury
largely sided with johnny depp awarding
him 10 million dollars in compensatory
damages and 5 million in punitive
damages heard was granted a smaller win
in her counter suit when jurors awarded
her 2 million dollars in compensatory
damages over comments made by depp's
attorney adam walden
she was given nothing for punitive
damages the verdicts came after six
weeks of testimony stemming from
allegations that heard defame depp in
her 2018 washington post op-ed about
domestic violence while debt suit heard
for 50 million heard counter sued for a
hundred million doubling down on abuse
claims in an exclusive interview with
dateline amber heard says she is
terrified she would be sued again by
depp saying the defamation lawsuit was
meant to take her voice heard also
doubled down on abuse allegations saying
depp has physically assaulted her
when your life is at risk
not only will you take the blame for
things that you shouldn't take the blame
for but when you're in an abusive
dynamic psychologically
emotionally and physically you don't
have the luxury of saying hey this is
black and white he says he never
hit you
never is that a lie yes it is not one
woman has come forward and said he
physically hit them you were the only
one look what happened to me when i came
forward
would you
joining us today is law and crime
analysts richard schoenstein and co-host
terry austin richard winning a civil
suit hasn't stopped heard so is there
anything johnny depp can do to stop her
from saying she was abused by him like
an injunction for example
yeah i guess in theory johnny depp could
go back to court and seek an injunction
getting her to stop but that would be
really difficult two reasons first it's
always very difficult to get an
injunction against speech that's one of
the hardest things to get in the courts
because we don't want to stop people
from talking but one second is one of
the big problems here would be to get
that injunction he'd have to show harm i
don't know what harm she's causing
because nobody believes her so who cares
if she goes on nbc and tells her story
again if it's not believed if it's not
adversely affecting johnny depp why
would he need an injunction
makes sense and plus he'll be wasting a
lot of money but i think camille vazquez
would love the business but terry
amber heard continues to say that johnny
depp physically and sexually abused her
now we've talked about injunction the
other question now is could she be
subjected to another defamation suit by
johnny depp well she could be but i
agree with richard for the same reasons
that it doesn't really make sense to try
to get an injunction at this point it
really doesn't make sense to try to
bring another defamation lawsuit she
would have to show damages he would have
to go through the whole same thing again
and it's not necessary he's proved his
case he's shown that her statements were
defamatory she's repeating those
statements and she does have a first
amendment right to say what she's
thinking so i don't think he's going to
go back into court honestly i think i
would try in some way to come to some
sort of agreement with her that she will
stop saying these statements in public
because at some point it's just got to
be exhausting as far as the depth team
is concerned yeah i can see the most of
people being 50 50. maybe they want to
see another johnny depp amber heard
trial and another group saying we don't
want to see them ever again so we'll
keep eyes on it and see if something
does come up these allegations and
statements
and in florida recently acquitted of the
top charges danielle redlich is released
from jail just hours after a verdict is
handed down relic was charged with
second-degree murder and evidence
tampering for the murder of her husband
michael redlich redlich claimed she
killed him in self-defense when she
stabbed him in 2019 the two had been
married for nearly 20 years and had two
children together defense attorneys say
the couple's relationship had a history
of abuse and cheating the couple had
also reportedly filed for divorce by the
time of michael's death 9-1-1 calls
reveal redlich initially told
dispatchers that michael stabbed himself
and had a heart attack investigators say
she waited several hours before calling
for help the night of his death
after only four hours of deliberations
jurors reached a verdict last friday
state of florida versus danielle justine
redlin
verdict as to count one we the jury find
the defendant not guilty
so say we all signed juror badge number
283 for person
special findings this page was left play
verdict as to count two we the jury find
the defendant guilty of tampering with
physical evidence as charged in the
information so say we all signed journal
badge number 283 for person
dated at orlando orange county florida
on the 17th day of june
2022. while a judge initially denied the
defense's motion for redlich to be
released she was bonded out hours after
the ruling relic is now set to be
sentenced on august 5th for the
tampering with evidence conviction
also in florida the so-called candy the
dog civil trial is put on hold after
three jurors test positive for coven 19.
the case stems from an incident in 2016
when defendant zachary dieterle sean
killed candy a terrier mix the lawsuit
was brought on by ronnie jacobson
candy's owner and a witness to the
shooting didley claims the dog was in an
attack stance when he shot her local
officials say dieterle was not charged
because he had a permit to carry the
weapon and feared for his life and that
he was within his rights to use deadly
force because he feared the dog would
kill him jacobson says candy had no
history of aggression he says the
ultimate goal of the trial is for the
sarasota sheriff's office to determine
the shooting was not justified and to
file criminal charges against deederly
the trial is expected to resume on
thursday stay with law and crime daily
for the latest developments
still ahead on law and crime daily why
jurors must restart deliberations in the
civil trial of comedian bill cosby but
first the deadly waukesha holiday parade
will the upcoming jury trial remain in
waukesha county
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the man officials say drove
his vehicle into wisconsin holiday
parade changes his plea from not guilty
to not guilty by reason of mental
disease or defect law on crime daily
first brought you the story last
november when officials say 40 year old
daryl brooks crashed his vehicle into
the annual holiday parade and did not
stop driving when hitting people or
barriers
six people were killed in the incident
and dozens more injured brooks now faces
83 charges in waukesha county including
multiple homicide charges battery
domestic abuse bail jumping recklessly
endangering safety and hit and run
involving a death brooks appeared in
waukesha county court on monday
officially changing his plea while the
judge denied moving the october jury
trial out of waukesha county she ruled
jurors will be partially sequestered for
the case that means jurors are required
to remain at the courthouse during the
day but can return home at night they
will meet at different confidential
locations every morning to be
transported by law enforcement to the
courthouse once there jurors will use a
secure entrance to get inside during the
lunch and court recesses jurors will
have limited access to their cell phones
the trial is expected to last all of
october all right terry changing his
plea what does that mean for this case
and why do you think he did it
you know he did it because the evidence
is clear he committed the act there were
multiple witnesses they took him in
immediately so i think that he and his
counsel recognized the fact it was far
better to plead not guilty by reason of
insanity and defect so what he has to do
here is prove that he does have this
defect and he has to show that he didn't
understand he lacked the capacity to
appreciate the difference between right
and wrong if he in fact can do that even
if he did commit this crime then he
would probably go to a mental
institution so i think they decided just
take chances they would do it this way
instead of just pleading not guilty and
in fact the jury could find that he did
it but he was insane and so he doesn't
have to go to jail for the rest of his
life absolutely now richard the judge
ruled that the case stays where it is
but with so much publicity and so many
victims what are the odds local jurors
haven't researched the case or at least
know someone involved
well i think it's very hard to get a
jury here that doesn't know something
about this event it was so prominent and
affected the community
the question for the judge is really is
that any better if we move to a
neighboring county and it sounds like
the judge didn't think it would be so
the judge has taken other steps in this
trial they're going to bring in a bigger
jury pool to select from they're going
to give the lawyers more opportunities
to strike jurors and they're going to
put in these partial sequestering rules
that you mentioned in your opening and
those are all designed to mitigate the
risk of having a jury that already has
an opinion about this case
yeah it's going to be interesting i'm
going to bet there's going to be a lot
of struggles finding a jury and it might
eventually move but we've got to see how
it plays out first the judge is doing
their best to ensure that doesn't occur
and then minnesota the trial for two
four minneapolis officers still facing
state charges in connection with george
floyd's death is being moved again jay
alexander king and two tao are charged
with aiding and abetting second-degree
murder and second-degree manslaughter in
the 2020 killing of floyd his death
sparked nationwide protests over use of
force and discrimination another officer
thomas lane pled guilty last month to
the aiding and abetting second-degree
manslaughter and all three officers were
previously convicted in federal court of
violating floyd's rights former officer
derek chovin is currently serving a 22
and a half year sentence for kneeling on
floyd's neck for more than nine minutes
murdering him king and towels state
trial was set to begin last week then
was delayed to january on friday state
prosecutors requested a speedy trial on
behalf of floyd's family in response
king's defense attorney on sunday
requested an even longer delay until
april prosecutors and defense attorneys
came to an agreement to now start the
trial in october the three former
officers are still awaiting sentencing
for their federal convictions
heading east to michigan where the
supreme court upholds a decades-long
prison sentence for larry nassar after
denying his request for a new sentencing
hearing
the former doctor pled guilty to in 2017
to sexually abusing countless gymnasts
under the care over the years the sexual
misconduct incidents occurred while
nassar was working as a team doctor at
michigan state university and as doctor
for team usa gymnastics his victims
included top olympic gymnasts simone
biles michaela moroney and ali raisman
among others more than 150 survivors of
nassau's abuse shared powerful victim
impact statements at his sentencing
where he received 40 to 175 years in
state prison nassar requested a
re-sentencing hearing which the judge
denied he then appealed the decision
alleging the judge was biased and
prejudiced the michigan court of appeals
upheld nassar's sentence survivors of
nassar's abuse are also seeking a one
billion dollar settlement from the fbi
saying agents mishandled the
investigation by making false statements
and ignoring reports of abuse for years
coming up on law and crime daily
survivors of the oxford high school
shooting point the finger to their
school district filing a federal lawsuit
plus deliberations begin again in the
civil trial of bill cosby what's at
stake for the disgraced comedian
[Music]
welcome back a california jury had to
start over to determine the outcome of a
case involving bill cosby as a comedian
and actor faces sexual assault
allegations in civil court
cosby is being sued by now 64 year old
judy hooth who claims he sexually
assaulted her at the playboy mansion in
the 1970s when she was just 16 years old
cosmis claimed there is no evidence
houth was ever at the mansion when the
alleged sexual assault occurred now
nearly 50 years later her case is the
first to head to court since his
criminal conviction and ultimate release
when it was thrown out for a sexual
assault alleged by a different woman the
jury began deliberating on thursday and
reportedly had decided on eight of the
nine verdicts by friday afternoon their
deliberations however were interrupted
when the courthouse was cleared at 4 30
to close down for the night a tight
budget wouldn't allow for deputies to
stay for overtime so the jury couldn't
reach a decision on all counts jurors
reconvened monday morning and had to
start deliberations over again after the
four person left for a prior obligation
with permission from the judge
cosby has denied whose accusations
against him as he has with the more than
50 women who have also accused him of
sexual assault
terry what does it mean to to restart
deliberations and
and why does that happen
well unfortunately it means they have to
restart deliberations they have to start
from the very beginning they have 12
jurors you have to have 9 out of 12.
they're out in santa monica and
california and so all nine of those
jurors have to discuss and deliberate
the entire case so they're starting all
over and it's unfortunate because the
excused person was the fourth person you
have to think that perhaps he was
leading those discussions it's unclear
how the alternate will affect those
deliberations but now they will have all
of the same 12 jurors they'll talk about
the case they've asked a question or two
already they wanted to know whether or
not the individual
you know reported the crime before the
statute actually ran out so they're
looking at all of the evidence very
carefully so we'll see what happens yeah
richard i get it
you're reading tea leaves by answering
this question but eight of the niner
decided i had to leave early
do you think the jury restarting favors
cosby or the plaintiff judy huth
i think it totally favors cosby for two
reasons one i think the jury was coming
in with a verdict that he was liable and
the reason i think that is because the
question remaining was about punitive
damages it wouldn't be a relative a
relevant question unless he was being
found liable so it's a chance for him to
get the jury to undo that the second
reason it's in his favor is it gives him
a potential ground for appeal that
they've substituted a jury and sent him
back to the drawing board to restart
deliberations that even if he loses now
he's got an argument to an appellate
court
yeah and cosby so far is one for one
with appeals and so maybe this is one
that he might be uh looking forward to
again well thank you for that input both
of you
and tesla and spacex ceo elon musk is
facing a multi-billion dollar federal
lawsuit from an investor who claims musk
is running a pyramid scheme the
plaintiff keith johnson accuses musk and
his companies of racketeering saying
they tied a dogecoin cryptocurrency and
purposely drove up its price to let it
then fall back down again
he's suing them for 258 billion dollars
saying musk was aware that dogecoin had
no value yet promoted it to profit from
its trading
that amount comes from johnson seeking
86 billion dollars in damages which
represents the decline in dogecoin's
market value since may of last year
johnson wants that amount tripled he
also seeks to block bus from promoting
the cryptocurrency and for a judge to
declare trading it gambling in may 2021
dogecoin traded at 74 cents that's down
to 5.8
also in celebrity news rob kardashian
and blac chyna will not be headed to a
jury trial as the former couple settles
outside of a courtroom blac chyna whose
real name is angela white alleged
kardashian illegally posted new photos
of her in 2017. following their breakup
according to court documents the pair
agreed to a settlement in the final hour
for the sake of their shared daughter
dream jury selection in the case was
expected to begin on monday this comes
just weeks after blac chyna lost a
defamation suit to rob kardashian's
mother kris jenner and sisters kim
kardashian khloe kardashian and kylie
jenner blac chyna argued the kardashian
jenner family defamed her as unstable
which led to the cancellation of her
reality show rob in china she argued
that created a loss of wages in the end
a california jury sided with the
kardashian jenner family and awarded
blac chyna no money in damages
when we come back a new lawsuit after
the oxford high school shooting as
families seek change in policies in the
upcoming school year
welcome back to law and crime daily the
families of about 20 students at a
michigan high school have filed a
federal lawsuit in a push for policy
changes in the district it comes seven
months after four students were shot and
killed at an oxford high school the 15
year old alleged gunman is charged with
24 accounts including first-degree
murder and terrorism after he allegedly
opened fire at an oxford high school in
november 30.
four students were killed eight others
including a teacher were seriously
injured the gunman is being charged as
an adult and has pled not guilty to all
charges his parents james and jennifer
crumbly are also facing involuntary
manslaughter after allegedly failing to
recognize warning signs ahead of the
shooting the lawsuit isn't asking for
monetary compensation but rather for
transparency and changes the upcoming
school year the students claim the
district is violating their right to a
safe learning environment arguing there
are currently harmful policies in place
which also allowed the shooter to return
to class before the shooting despite the
school allegedly knowing he was suicidal
and was having homicidal thoughts
richard why why is there so much
litigation when it seems everyone wants
the same thing answers will this cause
delays in getting them that very thing
they're looking for
everybody wants answers but i suppose
they have different approaches to how to
get them you want to investigate this
you want the investigation to be quick
you want it to be thorough and you want
it to be fair so that puts in
controversy a lot of issues the most
prominent of which is who should do the
investigation
should the school do it which seems like
it might be tilted or should someone
independent be brought in that seems to
me appropriate fodder for litigation
yeah my vote independence always a
better look now terry how does a civil
suit work when no money is being
requested if the 20 students win do they
get to create the policy
you don't have to have an amount of
controversy necessarily if you have a
u.s agency involved or if you have a
constitutional question which is what we
have here they are saying that their
constitutional rights were violated and
they are saying that they do have some
input on that policy they want the
policy to be transparent and they want
safeguards to be implemented so they
certainly do have some input there and
ultimately the
final resolution could be better
policies for the safety of those
students
that's hoping for better policies not
only here but across the country well
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you